Hi, my name is David Brown and this is a reading writing class.
Persuasive in your communication be useful for you, your studies, your future
career, and etc.
Being more persuasive in your communication be useful for you.
To be more persuasive means to be able to get other people to do what you want.
To do what you want, exactly.
How to be more persuasive?
Well, you have to learn, they say, once I heard, once you know the crowd you are talking to,
you have to learn how to talk the same way they talk so they can understand you better.
But at the same time, with their same words, with the same way they talk,
you have to teach them something.
And once you teach, they can be able to follow you.
I think everyone has something that they can persuade us of if they just have the ability
to do that, those communication skills to talk and express themselves well.
It's not easy.
No, it's not easy, I agree.
It can be difficult.
And this is something that we can improve.
We can learn how to be more persuasive in our communication.
And something that Frederick Douglass teaches us about, if you read his autobiography and we'll
read a section of it today, you'll notice just how persuasive he is.
He's just a really good writer, a really great persuasive writer for this cause.
And his words made a big impact because he was so persuasive.
So recap here, who was Frederick Douglass exactly?
You can see a collage of images here.
This is from the pre-civil war, civil war era.
You can see other examples of abolitionists in this photo here.
So he was born in 1818 and died in 1895.
Of his prime was during the Civil War, he was an African-American social reformer, abolitionist,
or writer, writer, and statesman.
Can you read this part for us here?
After escaping from slavery in Maryland, he became a national leader of the abolitionist movement.
Famous for his powerful speeches and writings?
Excellent. In fact, Abraham Lincoln knew about this man and had read his writings.
And it was some of his writings that inspired him to go along with this movement.
So we have a chart here.
We're going to think about what we know already about Frederick Douglass,
maybe what I've told you already, or what you've heard before, or what you know about the
Civil War already. What do you know already about this abolitionist or the Civil War?
From what you told me, well, he is an African-American, a slave.
He learned to read from others.
He wasn't taught how to read, but he learned from hearing other people how to read, right?
And he died of 77 years old, and he escaped from slavery in Maryland.
And once he learned how to read, he was a famous .
He was a famous writer.
Writer. Famous abolitionist and writer. Excellent.
You're a good listener. Thank you.
Now, there are new things to learn here. What questions do you have about Frederick Douglass?
What kind of things would you like to know about him?
Oh.
Okay, it says that he escaped from slavery. Why did he do after that?
Yeah.
And how do you think you'll find out? Well, I think we can find out through today's lessons and
activities, but actually what we're going to read today has more to do with his thoughts before
he escaped. I still think you can have some idea about what he had to do or what led him to
being able to escape. And this is something else that maybe you'll be able to
read after this lesson today as well if you'd like to finish reading his autobiography.
And some of his writings. So we have some vocabulary that we need to focus on. We'll read a passage
from Frederick Douglass's autobiography where he describes his determination to learn to read
and write. Nothing could stop this guy. He did everything he could to educate himself in
a world in which it was very taboo for a slave to learn to read and write.
Okay. These are some vocabulary words that we need to know here. I'd like for you to take a look
at these and their definitions. We have strategies. Can you read the definition for me here?
Clever tricks. Clever tricks are plans used to achieve a goal.
Deprovity.
I cannot see it out. Moral corruptions or wickedness. Wickedness.
About this one. Shuttle. In item of first, how do you pronounce it?
Shuttle. Shuttle. It sounds like a French, right?
An item or personal property. In slave people were legally
considered shuttle. So it's basically like a worthless object. They were treated like just
objects, just things that could be used and thrown away. And this one precepts, precepts.
Rules are principles guiding behavior. Apprehension.
You hear me.
Apprehension. You hear me? Apprehension.
Fear. Now I can. Fear and anxiety that something bad will happen. Also understanding.
No. Urchins.
Urchins mischievous. No, I don't know how to pronounce it.
Mischievous. Mischievous.
Often poor and regularly closed children.
They have sea urchins. Sea urchin is the type of sea creature with spikes on it.
But you can use them to describe children to urchins for good.
And this one, vindication. Vindication.
And vindication. Clearing someone of blame. Oh, and suspicious. Proof that someone or something is
right or reasonable. And a boy. A boy. To regard with disgust and hatred.
And hatred.
So we use this as a verb to abore something, to really hate something.
So a lot of these words really highlight some of the things that we'll talk about through our
reading or read together. When we read, we'll try to focus on the meaning, although I can help you with
pronunciation. I don't want it to.